All right.
So
I am,
I'm really kind of hoping that at least
30% of you will be severely unhappy with
this lecture.
So,
because,
and maybe that's wrong,
I'll find out afterwards.
This is a very,
this dimension of personality.
Agreeableness is one of the dimensions
that most particularly differentiate men
and women and obviously the differences
or similarities between men and women is
a matter of hot debate in our society.
Um,
and,
and I want it run through the science
that's associated with that.
And then,
well,
I guess then we'll see what,
what we conclude.
Now
you remember that the big five were
derived from a statistical analysis of
the content of language.
Hey,
that's kind of interesting because it
means that in so far as any
psychological theory in the history of
psychology has been a theoretical with
the possible exception of intelligence
research,
which was also the Iq is also derived
statistically.
Um,
it was derived by golden or it was
initially theorized by golden in some
sense back in the late 18 hundreds.
But what Golden Thought of as Eminence
bears very little relationship to what
the psychometric,
what the psychometricians measure as
intelligence.
So intelligence is a statistical
construct or Iq is a statistical
construct and the big five traits are
statistical constructs.
And what that means is that there,
there are theoretical presumptions that
went into their derivation,
but it's very difficult to think of them
as political because the first
hypothesis was only that
the fundamental dimensions of
personality would be reflected in the
language English to begin with.
But then other languages as the research
progressed around the world,
it's very difficult for me to understand
that as a political theory.
You know,
cause if scientific findings have
political implications,
then you have to wonder if the biases of
the researchers put the political
implications into the data before
revealing them as data.
But it's very difficult to argue that.
I think with regards to trait theories,
the other thing that happened with trait
theories is that the statistical
analysis suggested their existence.
It wasn't until after the traits were
reasonably well identified.
And this really started to kick in in
the 90s that we started to under stand
the potential biological basis and,
and even the nature,
the descriptive nature of the traits it
out the aspect level now where you
differentiate the big five into 10
there's still aspects that that we don't
know much about.
We don't know.
Like we don't really understand the
difference between politeness and
compassion.
We know that liberals are more
compassionate than,
than conservatives and conservatives are
more polite than liberals and we think
that politeness is somehow associated
with the tendency of conservatives to
follow social rules.
But that's about,
I would say that's about all we know
now.
We don't even know how much difference
there will turn out to be between polite
politeness and compassion.
But were there are ongoing studies
trying to understand the covariates and
correlates of the aspects.
And the same is true of the traits.
Um,
there was a lot of argument about
openness when it first was discovered
statistically.
Some people like Hans Isaac who
formulated some of the early three
dimensional models of personality.
And that was extroversion,
neuroticism and psychotic racism,
which he thought would predict the
proclivity towards schizophrenia but
actually turned out to be composed of
low agreeableness and low
conscientiousness.
Isaac didn't even think that openness
was a reasonable trade.
He thought it was mostly captured by Iq.
And actually that seems to be the case
to some degree because if you divide
openness into intellect and openness to
experience,
it looks like Iq loads on intellect or
at least the nonverbal part of Iq loads
on intellect where the verbal part of Iq
tends to load more on openness and
sodas,
openness to experience and so does
creativity.
But this is all discovered after the
fact.
So now one of the things that's happened
as a consequence of parsing out
personality into the big five traits and
also using other traits schemas is that
it's quite clear that there are
differences between the sexes or if you
like differences between the genders.
Now this is a thorny problem and it's
thorny for a number of reasons.
One reason is that it's a dogmatic
assumption proposition of social
constructionists that gender differences
are socially constructed.
First of all,
they separate out the idea of sex,
which you could think of as bio
biological sex you could think of is
chromosomal sex.
I presume that's one thing,
but gender,
that's a whole different thing and
gender is the manner in which men and
women present themselves to the world in
terms of differences in,
well,
anything that you can measure that's
above the fundamentally biological
level.
Maybe you could say anything above the
chromosomal difference,
like I don't exactly know where the
distinction is supposed to be made
between biological sex and gender.
It's not a simple thing to understand,
but the proposition is still obtains
that if there are differences between
men and women at the level of phenotypic
manifestation,
then they're socially constructed.
The problem with that is that it seems
to be wrong and not just a little bit
wrong,
but wrong,
right to the core,
and one of the things that I would like
to propose to you is that the social
constructionists only have theory on
their side.
I don't believe they have any data to
support their claims whatsoever.
Now,
I also think that they wouldn't accept
the sorts of things that I'm going to
talk to you about as data,
but that's a whole different argument.
MMM.
I don't really understand how it's
possible for people in an,
in the modern world to reject scientific
claims given that almost everything they
do in their day to day life that has
anything to do with technology
whatsoever,
depends for its function on the validity
of the scientific theories that underpin
the technology.
So what that means is that people who
treat scientific data as if it's just
another form of information,
socially constructed information,
certainly don't behave like that if you
follow them around in the actual world.
Now,
here's the proposition about
agreeableness.
I don't know if this is the case because
as I said,
there's lots of things we don't
understand about the big five
dimensions,
but this is how I've worked it out for
my own understanding and it's in
accordance with the data in so far as I
can determine that
agreeableness seems to be the dimension
between,
we certainly know,
agreeable people were empathic and
compassionate and polite.
We know less about disagreeable people,
although we know that they're more
likely to be male.
Now you could associate being
disagreeable with being more callous and
more harsh and more selfish in that if
you had to bargain with someone who's
low in agreeableness,
they would fight harder for their side
of the equation than someone high in
agreeableness would fight for.
There's now,
there's a couple of things about human
beings that that aren't considered
sufficiently.
I believe in so far as we conceptualize
human personality.
And one is that humans are unbelievably
maternal,
both genders.
They have to be,
because our babies are born for a mammal
of our size.
That gestation period should be two
years,
nine months.
And so what that means is that babies,
human babies are already born premature.
And you can tell that because you know
like ungulates deer thinking gears and
Angelette,
it doesn't matter pretty much as soon as
they're born,
they can stagger up on their legs and
start to run around.
Whereas a human baby isn't doing that
till 15 months or 13 months or 17 months
or depending on the baby,
you know,
so,
and babies are pretty much completely
helpless at birth and so they need a
tremendous amount of care.
And then because we have such a large
cortex and because we're so behaviorally
plastic,
we have an extraordinarily long
dependence and development period.
You know,
it's a minimum,
it depends on the culture,
but it's a minimum of 13 years and it
can certainly extend far beyond that and
does in cultures where there's a
tremendous amount of inculcation of
information.
So we also know that maternal behavior
is very common among mammals.
I mean the very definition of mammal in
some sense has to do with maternal
behavior because mammals,
well they bear live young and they
produce milk with her warm blooded and
they,
there's some other characteristics.
So,
so the ability to care for helpless,
okay.
Frequently upset,
dependent
creatures for a very long period of time
is part of our behavioral repertoire.
Now then you might wonder are there
individual differences in the degree to
which people are maternal?
And I think that's captured,
at least in part with agreeableness,
it makes sense because on the positive
pole of agreeableness,
that's where you get warmth and
compassion and empathy and the desire to
care for others and and self sacrifice.
I would say one of the things will will
show later is that agreeable.
This is negatively correlated with
income,
which is exactly what you'd expect if
you were negotiating with someone who
was self sacrificing because they're not
going to put forward their side of the
power equation as forcefully as someone
who is disagreeable.
So,
but you know,
in order to raise a baby you have to be
self sacrificing.
There is no two ways about it.
You might find that rewarding and
worthwhile,
but I don't believe there is a parent
who actually becomes a good parent who
doesn't put their child's welfare first.
And I think that's particularly true of
mothers,
particularly in the first year after
birth.
It's probably true right up to the age
of three,
but I think it's virtually undeniably
true for the first year.
The question is,
is that
reflected in personality traits?
Now,
the other thing about people that it's
worthwhile recognizing is that
we're hunters.
All right.
People are coniferous are pretty damn
good at bringing down big game.
It's reasonable to suppose that the
reason that there aren't as many large
animals in North America as there are in
Africa is because when human beings came
into North Africa,
North America,
15,000 years ago,
they killed all of them.
They killed all the Mammas,
they killed all the giant bears,
they killed all the cats,
they killed all the,
I think there were camels,
maybe can't remember precisely.
Anyways,
there was a very large array,
a very large mammals,
and they started to disappear pretty
damn quickly after the period of time
where people migrated into North
America.
Now,
one of the theories is that in Africa,
the animals and the people call evolved
so that the animals and the people had
fallen into some sort of mutual
stability.
But in North America,
that wasn't the case at all.
I don't,
I don't think it was that easy to bring
down a mammoth with a spear.
So it was very destructive of people to
do what they did.
But it also says volumes about what
human beings are like and it's certainly
the case that a non trivial proportion
of the human population still hunts and
they'll do that for leisure,
which is something that's very difficult
for people who aren't countries to
understand and they're almost all men,
which I don't think will come as a
surprise to anyone.
So I think that predatory aggression is
on the other side of agreeableness
and we also know that the best predictor
of whether or not you're going to be in
prison is low agreeableness.
Now low conscientiousness also helps,
but the fundamental marker of antisocial
behavior in so far as it's captured by
the big five personality markers seems
to be low agreeableness.
And that you might also say given that
men are less agreeable than women,
that that's part of the reason why
men are much more likely to be in prison
than women.
I think it's between,
okay,
I think it's 91% of incarcerated
criminals are male,
but I'm certain that it's above 80% I
believe it's 91%
now one of the things about
personality traits that you want to keep
in mind is that we,
they're normally distributed
and you need to understand some things
about the normal distribution.
If you're going to understand how
personality affects social outcomes
because it looks like men are only about
a half standard deviation less agreeable
than women and what that means if you
pull a given woman out of the population
in a given man,
you can by no means say for certain
which of those two are going to be less
agreeable.
On average it's going to be the man,
but there's not a huge difference in,
it's still quite highly probable that
the woman will be the least agreeable of
the two.
Now a normal distribution presupposes a
mean
and then random distribution around the
and one of the things that you'll learn
in psychology is that variables are
normally distributed and that's actually
not true.
Some variables are normally distributed
and lots aren't.
And you need to know about the ones that
aren't because a lot,
many of them are extremely important.
Wealth is not normally distributed.
Creative ability is not normally
distributed any.
Anything that has to do with the human
propensity to produce is not normally
distributed.
What happens is that in in those
situations,
almost every one does nothing and a very
tiny fraction of the people do
everything.
So for example,
I suspect that the median number of
records that you people have
produced is zero.
So,
and that's,
that's the case for very many phenomena
that are associated with creativity.
There are some things that are normally
distributed in personality traits seem
to be one of them.
The effect of personality traits on
production might not be,
but the personality traits themselves
are.
And so you can see if you look at this
distribution,
this is something you really have to
know and understand.
If you're going to understand research
and psychology,
this is like a basic axiom of all the
statistics.
The first axiom is that the phenomena
that you're measuring are normally
distributed.
Generally when you do a statistical
analysis,
you have to test to see if that's true.
And most statistics can handle a fair
bit of deviation from normality without
being rendered invalid.
But the list of variables that I just
described to you,
say those that are associated with
creative production do not fall into
that category.
They have very long tails there.
They're distributed according to
something called the prieto
distribution,
which we'll talk about more when we get
to conscientiousness and trade openness.
Now you'll see there's a middle line
there and that's the mean and the median
and the mode in a real normal
distribution.
And then the curve is divided up into
equal sections,
roughly four of them on each side of the
distribution.
So eight in total that represent a way
of representing the normal distribution.
And so by the time you get out to three
standard deviations above the mean,
you're talking about 0.1% of the
population.
So,
and the same thing is true on the other
end.
Three standard deviations below the
mean.
So basically the entire population is
encompassed within eight standard
deviations.
Now it's not quite because the tails
keep going.
There's just fewer.
There's so few people out there at one
point that you know they vanish into
almost,
they almost vanish.
That doesn't mean they're not,
their existence is not necessarily
important.
You know,
one guy who's six standard deviations
below the mean in agreeableness might be
the serial killer who killed,
kills a hundred people.
So those exceptions can still have
extraordinarily powerful impacts.
They're just not statistically very
common.
Now the normal distribution for man and
women overlaps quite a lot for most
single personality traits.
So women are half a standard deviation,
more agreeable than man.
So you can imagine two curves that
overlap with the female distribution
being shunted slightly to the right.
And so what that means,
as I said,
if you take out a random woman or a
random man from the distribution,
it's somewhat of a toss up who's going
to be more or less agreeable.
However,
if the situation is such that only the
person who's one in a hundred least
agreeable ends up in prison,
all of the people who end up in prison
are going to be men.
Because the consequence of shifting the
curves slightly to the right is that
when you move out to the left hand side
of the distribution,
outstay three standard deviations in the
entire population,
all of the people out there are going to
be man.
So what that means is that small
differences in the mean,
even if the distribution is,
is the same shape,
small deviations from the mean can
produce huge,
huge social effects at the periphery.
So you know,
here's an example,
there aren't that many people who are
five standard deviations above the mean
and intelligence.
But among them are a tremendous number
of Nobel prize laureates.
So because you can understand with
intelligence,
it isn't exactly how smart you are that
matters.
It's how smart you are compared to other
people.
Cause if you're smarter than other
people,
you're going to get to where everyone's
going faster.
And it's the fastest person who it's the
person who's fastest at that,
who's going to get there first.
So comparative ability really,
really matters when you're looking at
exceptional levels of ability of,
of productive output.
It's a rough law.
So here,
here's a rule.
This is called price's law.
The square root of the number of people
in a domain do half the work is that
means if there's 10,000 neuroscientists,
10,000 publishing neuroscientists,
a hundred of them have half the
publications
and most of them have zero or one.
So the rule for publications is among
Phd students is
the median number of publications that
Phd students have is somewhere between
zero and one half is many have to half
as many of that has three,
half as many as that have four.
So it's a tremendous step down in
productivity as it's an exponential
stepped down in probability with a
linear step up in productivity.
It's a very,
very frightening fact.
Now,
it accounts for why 1% of the population
has a huge chunk of the money.
But you know,
if you take that 1% and you divide them
into 99% and 1% the top 1% of the 1% has
almost all the money that the top 1%
house.
And then if you take the top 1% of 1%
and you divide them into 99% and 1% the
top 1% of that tiny slice has almost all
of the money that that tiny slice house.
So it's also scalable and it's a problem
because it means that productivity is,
is,
is always in the hands of a few and no
one knows what to do about that.
Or even if there's anything that can be
done about it or even if there's
anything that should be done about it.
So I know you might think of it as
unfair.
Well it's certainly on fair in terms of
egalitarian distribution of,
of productivity.
But what are you going to do about that?
Exactly.
It doesn't seem like stopping the people
who were hyper productive from being
hyper productive constitutes a useful
solution to that problem.
So,
and even if you allow huge populations
of people access to higher education,
that might boost the overall levels of
productivity,
but it doesn't change the distribution
partly because it just makes everything
more competitive.
Right?
So
here's the definition of gender that
basically it's basically the 1960s to 19
well to 2010 feminists.
Description of gender is socially
constructed system of classification
that ascribes qualities of masculinity
and femininity to people.
Gender characteristics can change over
time and are different between cultures.
Well,
there's a variety of claims in that.
One is that it's socially constructed
and the second is that it can change
over second and third that it changes
over time and are different between
cultures.
Yeah,
of course.
It depends on what you mean by different
and that's the key issue on what
measure,
which is something you can't
not ask when you make a statement like
that,
but that's the basic proposition.
I think the truth of the matter actually
is is that
you can make,
make a one to one mapping of personality
on to gender,
but that doesn't mean that personality
is socially constructed.
There isn't a lot of evidence that it
is,
it's certainly not socially constructed
in such a way that it would allow the
emergence of more than five dimensions.
It might be socially constructed,
at least to the degree that some one
society can push people regardless of
their gender or even regardless of their
personality,
farther up the distribution or farther
down the distribution.
Then another culture,
Mike.
So we know for example,
that
it takes us,
if you take kids who are adopted out
twins and you want to produce a 15 point
difference in their Iq by the time
they're 18 you have to have a minimum of
three standard deviations difference in
wealth between the families that they
lambed in.
So that's what a one standard deviation
increase intelligence costs.
And that's a lot.
And it isn't even obvious that that gain
sustains itself across the entire
lifespan because one of the things that
happens is that as identical twins who
were separated at birth and raised in
different families age,
their Iq is become more like each other
until by the time they're about 60 their
iqs are so similar that it's as if
you're testing the same person twice.
And that's weird day because what you
would think you would definitely think
that well as once you separate the
twins,
the longer they stay apart,
the more different they're going to be.
Right?
Because you would assume that their
environments stay different and the
differences are going to accumulate
across time and that they're going to
divert.
But that isn't what happens at all.
Okay.
So let's look at some,
some interesting things here.
So here's one study.
There's a,
one of the things you might ask yourself
is
why do boys like to play with trucks and
girls like to play with like stuffed
animals and dolls,
roughly speaking.
And one answer is,
well that's socially constructed
parents,
whether they want to or not
differentially reinforce toy preferences
subtly and directly.
And as a consequence that the cumulative
effect of that determines what toys the
children are going to play with.
Um,
it's not obvious from the literature
that that's the case,
but
that's not a theory that can explain
this.
So what the researchers was take a whole
variety of toys and have a number of
people classify them as either feminine,
stereotyped or masculine stereotype.
And then they give them to a number of
children to see which toys,
which gendered children played with.
And they found that the male children
tended to play with the stereotypically
masculine toys given free choice and the
female children tended to play with the
female stereotype toys given choice.
Well,
that doesn't have anything to do at all
with the socialization hypothesis,
except they did the same thing with
rhesus monkeys.
We compare the interactions of 34 rhesus
monkeys living within 135 monkey troop
with human wheeled toys and plush toys.
Male monkeys like boys showed consistent
and strong preferences for wheeled toys.
While female monkeys like girls show
greater variability at preferences.
That's the magnitude of preference for
wheeled over plush toys different
significantly between males and females.
The similarities to human findings.
The top graph,
by the way,
is human subjects.
In the bottom graph is monkey subjects.
On the left you see males.
Um,
the black bar is masculine toys and on
the right you see females where the
black bars,
masculine toys.
Now,
what you see is the females are more
likely to play with masculine and
feminine toys,
although they slightly prefer feminine
toys,
whereas the males overwhelmingly prefer
masculine toys.
The similarities to human findings
demonstrate that says preferences can
develop without explicit gendered
socialization.
We offer the hypothesis that toy
preferences reflect hormonally
influenced behavioral and cognitive
biases,
which are sculpted by social processes
into the sex differences seen in monkeys
and humans.
Okay.
Janice M Hassett was the lead author on
that
paper.
That's kind of a rough one.
It's a,
it's not obvious at all why male rhesus
monkeys would want to play with wheel
toys.
I mean,
what the hell?
Right?
I mean,
it's not like rhesus monkeys.
They're driving around in trucks,
you know?
So it's not exactly clear why these
differences exist when you're thinking
about how they're responding to plush
toys,
you know,
those are basically pseudo infants.
So that's kind of an easier thing to,
to understand,
especially because we know that the,
the hallmarks of cuteness,
which,
which is the stimuli that are necessary
to evoke a,
basically a maternal response,
the hallmarks of cuteness are pretty
much stable across mammals,
which is why people think kittens are
cute and you know,
and uh,
well any little baby thing is cute and
the reason for that is big i's and
little nose and it sort of moves
helplessly.
It has short limbs and all of that sort
of adds up to cute and cute is a very
powerful set of triggering stimuli.
So if it wasn't obviously children who
were playing with little like plush
bears wouldn't baby them,
you know,
because obviously a plus there is not a
baby,
but it's similar enough to a baby
schematically that it evokes
automatically evokes those sorts of
responses.
You know,
when,
um,
when my,
my daughter used to have this stuff toy
and it was a cat and I used to play with
that cat.
And one thing I used to do with it is
you could actually push its head inside.
It's little plus body know that she did
not find that the least bit of music.
So that's a difference in masculine and
feminine play patterns there too.
So,
you know,
she knew perfectly well that this thing
couldn't be hurt.
That wasn't the issue.
You know,
the,
the behavioral responses that it evoked,
we're part of a sect,
you know,
and it was perfectly healthy of her to
be responding as if this thing was
deserving of caring,
compassionate.
She was practicing doing that is a very
important thing to do.
It needs practice.
Okay.
Um,
I'll read this to you now.
I think some of the best research done
on why gender differences exist outside
of socialization has been done by,
um,
Simon Baron Cohen.
Simon Bar Cohen.
Okay.
He's a borats brother by the way.
Just so you know,
what he showed is that you might think
that the classical human body type is
female.
So in some sense,
every creature human creature starts out
with a prototypically female body
structure by,
and even though there's chromosomal
differences between the two sexes,
and what happens is that masculinization
occurs as a consequence of fetal
testosterone.
And there's a lot of variation in fetal
testosterone from male fetus to male
female fetus and some of Cohen's work
has demonstrated quite clearly that
field testosterone,
fetal testosterone levels are very much
associated with post birth masculine
behaviors.
And one of the things he's found out,
for example,
he believes that autism is hyper
masculinity because he's found that
the feeder old boys who are hyper
masculinized are much more likely to
become autistic.
And one of the things that's interesting
about autistic kids,
there are autistic females as well,
by the way,
but most of them are male,
is that the most fundamental lack they
seem to have is the lack of ability to,
to engage in any sort of social contact
whatsoever.
So they don't make eye contact and boys,
by the way,
boy,
babies make less eye contact and girl
babies,
the autistic kids,
they don't make hardly any I call to
contact at all.
And they have a very difficult time
establishing any kind of social
relationship.
Now this study is kind of interesting.
So it was published in,
I think it was 2012 let me,
let me read it to you.
Previous research has shown that
prenatal exposure to endocrine
disrupting chemicals can alter
children's neurodevelopment including
sex typed behavior and that it can do so
in different ways in males and females.
Non Chemical exposure including
psychosocial stress may disrupt the
prenatal hormonal meal you as well.
To date only one published study has
perspectively that means over time
examined the relationship between
exposure to prenatal stress and gender
specific play behavior during childhood.
Finding masculinized play behavior in
girls who experienced high prenatal life
events,
stress but no associations in boys.
Here we examine this question in a
second.
Prospect of cohort from the study for
future families.
Pregnant women completed questionnaires
on stressful events,
life events during pregnancy,
and those who reported one or more
events were considered stressed.
Families were recontact,
contacted several years later.
The mean age of their children was five
years and mother's completed the
questionnaire including the validated
preschool activities inventory which
measures sexually dimorphic play
behavior in sex stratified analysis
after adjusting for child's age,
parental attitudes towards gender
atypical play,
age and sex of siblings and other
relevant covariates girls exposed to
prenatal life events.
Stress had higher scores on the p s ai
masculine subscale.
Okay.
And showed a trend towards higher or
more masculine composite scores.
By contrast in males there was a trend
towards an association between prenatal
stress and Higher Psi Feminine subscale
scores but no association with masculine
or composite scores.
These data confirmed previous findings
of human and animal models suggesting
that prenatal stress is a non chemical
endocrine disruptor that may have
androgenic effects on female fetuses and
anti androgenic effects on male feed
fetuses,
androgenic being male hormone effected.
This is Simon Baron Cohen direct study.
Um,
one of the tests hypothetically that you
can use to assess empathy,
although it turns out to be rather
difficult to do that reliably,
is to use what's called the mind in the
eyes test.
And basically with that test,
what you do is you show subjects,
just a slice of a photograph of eyes.
The person in the photograph had been
manifesting some display of emotion and
some emotional displays are associated
with change.
And I,
so for example,
a Duchenne smile,
which is a true smile also involves
lifting of the eyes at the edge.
It's whereas just a like a fake social
smile is just the mouth.
So you can read a smile from the eyes.
Now you can't read that as well as you
could if you had the whole face.
You can read anger from the eyes because
the eyebrows,
you know,
it includes the eyebrows,
eyebrows go down and you can read
surprise and,
but it's kind of a tenuated because you
don't have the whole face.
And so hypothetically,
people who are more attuned to social
cues can do a better job of reading the
mind in eyes.
So these researchers looked at children
for whom fetal testosterone data was
available and then determined at how old
were they?
I don't remember.
It doesn't matter.
They have data on fetal testosterone
from obviously from before birth.
And then at some point in their child
development,
they were given this test.
Empathy involves an understanding of
what others are thinking and feeling and
enables us to interact and the social
world
according to the empathizing,
systematizing theory.
Now here's the theory.
The theory is that women are tilted
towards empathizing and males are tilted
towards systematizing.
And that that seems to fall into
alignment with other observations
suggesting that the biggest gender
difference between adult humans is
mmm.
Interest preference.
Women are much more likely to express
interest in occupations that involve a
lot of social contact,
whereas men are more likely to,
um,
manifest interest in occupations that
have to do with things.
And so one example of that,
you see this in the Scandinavian
countries,
despite the fact that they've really
done everything possible to flatten out
the environmental differences between,
um,
opportunities for,
for boys and for girls,
is that in the Scandinavian countries,
the ratio of male nurses to female
nurses is one to 20.
And of male of female engineers to male
engineers is one to 20.
And the government's now,
and then do a big push to try to get
more men into
mmm.
Into nursing and more women into
engineering.
And with a lot of push and a lot of
advertising and marketing and so forth,
they can shift the,
the proportions to some minor degree.
But as soon as they stop pushing hard,
they just snapped back to one in 20.
And it's really interesting if you think
about it,
that the biggest gender differences that
are reported in the world are reported
between men and women and Scandinavian
societies because those are the most
gender equal societies in the world.
And so one of the perverse things that
has happened is that you can imagine
that there's some reason that men and
women are different is because of
environmental,
very variability,
right?
The environment for the women and the
environment for the man is different.
And then some proportion is due to
genetic variability.
And so then one idea which is false is
that if you were radic hated the
environmental variability,
the gender differences would disappear.
That would only be the case if all the
gender differences were due to
environmental variability.
What happens instead is that when you
eliminate the environmental variability,
you maximize the genetic variability and
the reason you do that is because that's
all that's left,
right?
You've eradicated the other source of
variability,
so the only thing left is genetic
variability and the consequence of that
is being is that men and women differ
more in Scandinavia than they do in any
other place on the planet.
Now that to me that seems like the death
knoll of social construction theories
because it's exactly the opposite of
what would have been predicted precisely
the opposite.
You know,
and maybe it would've been a good thing
if flattening out the opportunity
landscape would have eradicated gender
differences in personality and
preference and so forth,
but it isn't self evident that that's a
good thing because you could also say
that I need galatarian.
Society optimally constructed is one in
which the differences between people are
allowed to manifest themselves so that
each person is able to find a place in a
niche and the society that actually fits
their temperament.
Empathy involves and understanding of
what others are thinking and feeling and
enables us to interact in the social
world according to the empathizing
systemizing theory.
Now part of this systemizing theory as
well is that one of the thing about
autistic people,
okay
is that they systematized like mad,
you know,
so to the degree that their cognitive
abilities are intact,
which is extraordinarily variable,
it's more often the case that if an
autistic child focus on focuses on
something,
they do it obsessively and what they do
is classify and systematize to a degree
that looks you need dimensional and and
well
you need dimensional and fundamentally
focused
according to the empathizing systemizing
theory,
females on average have a stronger drive
to empathize that males,
this sex difference May in part reflect
developmental differences in brain
structure and function,
which are themselves under the influence
of fetal testosterone.
Previous studies and found that fetal
testosterone is inversely backwards
correlated with social behaviors such as
eye contact and infancy,
peer relationships and preschoolers and
mentalistic interpretation of animate
motion.
Male fetuses are exposed to higher
levels of testosterone.
Then our female fetuses.
The present study investigates
empathizing and children as a function
of amniotic measures of fetal
testosterone.
193 mothers of children,
100 males 93 see males age six to eight
years of age,
completed children's versions of the
empathy quotient,
which is a questionnaire I believe and
children themselves.
We're tested on reading the mind in the
eyes task.
All mothers had had amniocentesis during
the second trimester of pregnancy.
There was a significant negative
correlation between fetal testosterone
and scores on both measures.
Well,
empathy may be influenced by postnatal
experience.
The results suggest that prenatal
biology also plays an important role
mediated by androgen effects in the
brain.
These results also have implication for
the causes of disability involving
empathy such as autism spectrum
conditions and may explain the increased
rate of such conditions among males.
Here's some differentiators between
compassion and politeness.
Compassionate people feel others'
emotions.
Inquire about others' wellbeing and
sympathize with other feelings,
others' feelings,
polite people.
Respect authority,
hate to seem pushy and avoid imposing
their will on others.
Okay,
so there's the,
okay.
The non overlapping distributions that
I,
okay.
Talk to you about
the probability that a randomly drawn
woman will be more agreeable than a
randomly drawn men is 63% so six if you
do random pairs 10 times,
six times,
the woman will be more agreeable than
the man that you chose.
So you see that it's not,
in some sense it's not a tremendous
difference.
You know it deviates from 50 50
obviously,
but it still leaves a lot of room for
the claim that men and women are
basically more similar than they are
different.
But then again,
it depends on where in the distribution
that you're looking because of the,
okay,
the increasing effects of a difference
in distribution.
Now as you move farther and farther out
to the edges of the population,
women are more extroverted than man by
0.15 of a standard deviation in
particular.
They're more enthusiastic after the
aspect level and enthusiastic and people
seem to manifest a lot of positive
emotion.
So it's quite interesting because one of
the things that that seems to imply is
that we know that women are also more
sensitive to negative emotion.
So women actually seem to have a broader
range of emotional expression than men.
They're more prone to positive emotion
and they're more prone to negative
emotion.
You UN index is of a gender equality and
economic development are associated with
larger differences in agreeableness but
not an extroversion or neuroticism.
So basically if you rank countries by
how
yeah,
favorably they look upon equal rights
and how much they've been able to put
that in practice.
The countries that rank higher in rights
for women produce women and men who are
more variable on agreeableness rather
than less.
But you don't see the effect of with
extroversion and neuroticism.
So
occupational preference,
it's the people things,
dimension men prefer working with things
and women with people.
And the difference is almost a full
standard deviation
and the end is 500,000 so you know when
you're starting to get up the numbers
like that in the study,
it becomes increasingly more reasonable
to consider it representative of the
actual population.
Holand John Holland has produced a
typology of jobs which he acronine turns
into an acronym,
which is reassess,
realistic,
imaginative,
artistic,
social,
entrepreneurial,
I believe.
And Conventional,
I'm not sure about the entrepreneurial
one man show stronger,
realistic and investigative interests
and women's show stronger artistic,
social and conventional interests.
Yeah,
and there's no differences in
enterprising.
It's not entrepreneurial ability.
It's enterprising.
This is fundamentally the same thing.
So how does that express itself and in
social terms,
while there are more men as well known
in science,
technology,
engineering and mathematics,
now God only knows if that'll be the
case in 20 years.
Because one of the things that's
happening to our society very rapidly is
that men are bailing out of higher
education institutions at a rate that's
nothing short of terrifying.
So I
already in educational institutions,
higher
edgy,
you know,
institutes of higher education,
women radically outnumber men.
And the rate at which they're,
that's changing seems it's in itself to
be increasing.
Why that is is not so obvious.
It's also the case that in pre higher
education settings,
increasingly girls outperform boys and
it's also not self evident why that is.
It's not a good thing.
Here's some gender differences in
employment.
One of the things that might interest
you might annoy you is that okay?
The most common occupation for women in
1956 was basically secretarial.
That's still the case,
although the names are different because
it's often administrative assistant or
executive assistant,
but the job descriptions are
fundamentally equivalent.
There's 11% women in construction,
15% women in forestry,
19% women in mining and 25% women in in
work.
That involves utilities.
There are no female brick masons,
block masons or stone masons.
0.1% very,
very few cement masons,
concrete finishers and turnout,
so workers,
very few electrical power line
installers and repairs.
Carpet floor and tile installers,
heating,
air conditioning,
refrigeration,
mechanics and installers,
structural iron and rebar workers,
bus and truck mechanics and diesel
engine specialists.
Miscellaneous vehicle in mobile
equipment,
mechanics,
installers and repairs.
Tile and do make dye makers tool and die
makers and roofers all under 1%.
Women.
This is the 10 most female dominated
occupations in the United States as of
2010 secretaries and administrative
assistants,
96% childcare workers,
95% receptionists and information
clerks,
93% teacher assistants,
92% registered nurses,
91% it's all around 90.
So while cops stop saying that,
bookkeeping,
accounting,
auditing,
maids,
housekeepers,
nursing,
psychiatric and home health aides,
personal and home care aides and general
office clerks.
All of those are 85% or more female.
Other differences between men and women.
Men are taller than women on average
five inches.
The average woman in North America is
five foot four and the average man is
five foot nine.
The average man weighs 194 pounds and
the average woman weighs 164 pounds.
Um,
men are 40 to 60% stronger in their
upper body
and they and their and their,
their jaw size is much larger.
That's because jaws are used for
aggression.
They're used for biting and so it's a
hangover from,
if you will,
a hangover from our more primordial
past.
Women have a higher proportion of body
fat,
they're more resistant to disease.
There are far more male homicide victim,
77% there are far more male homicide
perpetrators,
85% if women kill someone,
it's usually an intimate partner or
family member 60% of the time.
Whereas if men kill someone,
it's usually a non intimate acquaintance
or a stranger.
So obviously you're much safer with a
woman you don't know.
Yeah,
predation instrumental versus defensive
aggression,
8% of the male population hunts,
and that's 91% male.
Okay.
Now,
one of the things that is characteristic
of modern culture is that we associate
almost unthinkingly axiomatically
agreeableness with virtue,
and we think that compassion,
empathy
are
virtues that should predominate in
people's virtue hierarchy and that they
should be fostered.
But one of the things that's very much
worth considering is that all virtues
turned into vices.
If you push them far enough,
and that's part of the reason why they
would be normally distributed,
right?
Because every trait has a range within
which it's functional and outside of
that range,
the probability that it will be
functional starts to become very,
very low.
Now,
empathy,
warmth and compassion sound like very
good things,
but
they can also be construed as trusting,
submissive,
and compliant,
which could be perceived as naivete
docility and a tendency to follow rather
than lead.
Now we do know that one of the
predictors of dependent personality
disorder is high levels of agreeableness
and that that is a disorder that is more
characteristic of women and anxiety
disorders and depressive disorders are
also much more prevalent in women and
that's likely associated not with
agreeableness,
but with high levels of negative
emotion.
Now this paper 2001 is the effects of
personality on executive career success
in the U S and Europe.
Now,
you know,
everybody talks about the glass ceiling,
right?
And the idea that women make less money
than men for the same amount of work.
Well,
the first thing I would say is that's
not true for single people.
Just so you know,
and
it isn't obvious that the reason that
women make less money than men when they
do is because of prejudice.
So women are more likely to work part
time,
for example.
And the reasons for that are pretty
obvious.
All you have to do is think about that
for 15 seconds to figure out why.
And the reason is is that many women
have children in their thirties and one
of the ways of balancing the development
of your career with the burden of having
children or the wonder of having
children,
it depending on how you look at it,
is by working part time.
Now,
one of the problems with that,
well,
there's two problems potentially.
Well,
I'll show you the next slide before I
get into that.
Okay.
So
I'll go to this next one.
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's some correlations.
One of them is between how much money
you make and your personality.
So the correlation between neuroticism
and how much money you get paid is
negative 0.3.
The higher you are neuroticism,
the less you make,
less you get paid.
Why?
Why do you think that is?
Because you're not confident in your own
abilities.
You have low self esteem and if you're
not confident in your own abilities and
you're anxious about your performance,
the probability that you're going to
feel confident and calm about
negotiating for more money or even
asking for a raise is quite low.
Okay?
Extraversion and money made virtually no
correlation.
Openness,
no correlation.
Agreeableness,
negative 0.2 for now,
you might not think that those
correlations are very large,
but if the correlation between
neuroticism and money made is negative
0.3 if you translate that into an effect
size cause,
this is called a binomial effect size
distribution,
just the effect of neuroticism.
We'll ensure that 65% of men make more
money than average and 35% of women make
more money than average.
Just the effect of neuroticism and if
you add neuroticism and agreeableness
together,
I have to do the math because I have to
square,
I have to take the square root.
It's 0.5
0.5
I can't do that in front of a class.
Unfortunately it's going to push it up
to about 70 30 or higher than that.
There's a little bit of a negative
correlation between conscious
conscientiousness and money made
ascendancy.
How well you progress up the ranks.
Yes.
Directly or indirectly?
I don't know cause I,
I didn't look that,
I didn't look in detail into the models
they use,
so I was just going to stick to the zero
order correlations.
So ascendancy negative 0.2,
one for neuroticism,
negative 0.144
agreeableness,
the effects are larger if you totaled
them.
Let's see.
Here's a good one.
This is something to think about.
Job Satisfaction.
The correlation with neuroticism is
negative points for two.
That's a big one.
One of the things that's very
interesting about neuroticism is it's
also a very good predictor of marital
satisfaction.
And it's interesting in that light to
note that 70% of divorces are initiated
by women.
Now,
one reason for that is that men are
impossible to get along with.
And the other possibility is that women
are too sensitive to that and there's no
way of sorting that out,
but it's nonetheless interesting to note
that that's still where the gender
difference lives.
Neuroticism correlation with job
satisfaction,
negative 0.42 correlation with life
negative 0.42 correlation with career
satisfaction,
negative 0.41 so one of the things you
want to remember is that almost all the
measures that purport to measure
something like wellbeing or happiness or
satisfaction are so contaminated with
neuroticism that it's not even clear
that they're measuring something
different.
You see agreeableness,
the correlation with career
satisfaction,
just negative 0.2
if you get men to rate their performance
and you get their bosses to rate their
performance,
men rate their performance pretty much
the same as the bosses rate their
performance or maybe they rate them a
little bit more.
But if women rate their own performance,
they rate their own performance as worse
than their bosses rating of their
performance consistently.
And the predictor of that seems to be
negative emotionality.
Now you might wonder if negative
emotionality is something that's
associated with lower levels of life
satisfaction across a broad variety of
measures.
What possible use could it be?
But then you have to wonder,
well,
exactly how is the physical environment
different for women and for men?
And one clearer fact is that at an
individual level,
at least in relationship to dominance,
battles with men,
women are at a disadvantage,
not least because of their size.
Now it is the case,
for example,
that women hit men in marital
relationships more often than men hit
women.
Okay,
but that's,
that's the sort of statistic that makes
you wonder about measures and
statistics.
What's wrong with that measure?
Exactly.
That's exactly it.
You know,
so it depends.
It depends precisely on how you define
hit,
you know,
and it's a very tricky thing because it
could be frequency,
it could even be,
it could be frequency that that
certainly might be a measure,
but the best measure would likely likely
be something like damaged per blow.
Here's a study of the differences
between men and women.
At an aspect level.
Women are more enthusiastic,
one fifth of a standard deviation there,
a little less assertive,
but not very much.
Those are both elements of extroversion.
They're more compassionate,
almost half a standard deviation.
There are about a third of a standard
deviation,
more polite.
There's no difference in
industriousness.
Women are slightly more orderly than
men.
Here's something to think about.
This is something that I noticed,
for example,
when I was raising kids,
so I would intervene when my kids were
misbehaving far more often than my wife
would,
but if I could just shut up for five
seconds when they were being annoying,
then she had to intervene.
And all that meant was my threshold for
being annoyed by misbehavior was just
slightly lower than hers.
But what that meant in practice was
because it was lower,
I ended up doing,
I ended up intervening far more often
because I would get fed,
you know,
if it took her 63 seconds to get annoyed
and me 60 what that would mean
practically would be that I was
intervening most of the time.
So in women are a little bit more
orderly than men too.
So you might ask yourself what exactly
that would mean for the division of
Labor in a household.
Because what it suggests is that if
there's disarray in the household,
the probability is such that the tip of
a woman will get more annoyed about that
faster than the typical Matt and how
that would translate into the manner in
which household duties are distributed.
I don't know.
But it's important to remember that
small differences at the mean level can
produce very large differences in
behavior.
Women are lower and intellect and higher
and openness.
And I think that probably goes along
with the,
with the interest dimension,
we saw already that women are more
interested in artistic pursuits than men
are and that makes sense because we know
that the openness to experience part of
openness is a predictor for example,
of whether you were in the humanities or
in the sciences in university.
So intellect predicts roughly speaking,
interest in the sciences and openness to
experience predicts interest in the
humanities.
In the arts,
women are half a standard deviation,
more agreeable.
This is at the big five level and four
tenths of a standard deviation,
more sensitive to negative emotion.
So the two really big traits that
differentiate men from women are
agreeableness.
And negative emotion.
Now you might ask,
here's another chart that's quite
interesting.
Um
Huh.
Motivation variables by big five traits.
Evenings worked.
Extrovert.
Extroverts are more likely to work.
Evenings.
Agreeable people are less likely to work
evenings.
Now that's interesting because you might
think that if they were agreeable,
they'd work more evenings.
But I suspect that's what's happening
with the agreeable people is that
because their primary commitment is to
intimate relationships,
they're more likely to consider their
primary domain,
their responsibilities to intimate
partners of various sorts.
And so they'll goal work for that
reason.
Conscientious people work is more
central to their life.
It's also the case with open people.
So,
okay.
Uh,
the correlation between agreeableness
and hours worked is negative 0.16.
The correlation between agreeableness
and the hours of work that someone
desires is negative 0.17.
Okay.
Here's some things that predict,
um,
relationship instability on divorce.
Most personality traits have substantial
effects on mating and parenting related
behaviors such as sexual promiscuity,
relationship stability,
and divorce.
Promiscuity.
And the desire for multiple sexual
partners are predicted by extraversion
openness to experience neuroticism,
especially in women.
Positive skid sodomy,
which we won't bother with.
And the dark traits like narcissism,
psychopathy and machiavellianism,
negative predictors of promiscuity and
short term mating include agreeableness,
conscientiousness,
honesty,
humility.
In the HEXACO model,
which is a six dimensional model and
autistic light traits,
relationship instability is associated
with extroversion,
low agreeableness and low
conscientiousness.
Yeah,
that's,
that's high extroversion,
low agreeableness and low
conscientiousness.
That's tilting quite hard towards
psychopathy.
So someone who is really extroverted and
really low and really low in
agreeableness,
they tend to be narcissistic.
And that's not necessarily a problem if
they're high in conscientiousness,
cause you can still,
they might be selfish and after their
own interest,
but if they're high in
conscientiousness,
if they tell you that they'll do
something,
they'll do it.
And generally you can expect that.
They'll tell you the truth.
If they're low in conscientiousness,
well then you have a big problem because
they tend to be somewhat parasitical,
which is one way of defining low
conscientiousness and disagreeable.
So they only care about themselves and
extroverted.
So they're very dominant and outgoing.
So.
Okay.
Finally,
neuroticism,
low conscientiousness,
and to a smaller extent,
low agreeableness all contribute to
increase the likelihood of divorce.
Now in this study,
okay,
there is a 16 pdf study done.
You can't see it here because it's cut
off on this slide a couple of years ago.
What they did,
it's quite interesting.
Instead of just looking at the zero
order correlations between gender and
personality,
they summed all the differences to see
what the overall difference was between
men and women.
So you'd have one normal distribution
that was man and another normal
distribution that was women,
and then you could see how much they
overlapped.
If you summed up all the gender
differences,
and the answer was they were three
standard deviations different in total,
which is a whopping difference.
It meant that the personality
distributions of men and women over out
only overlapped in total by 10%
they found in the 16 pdf pdf,
Scotty,
that's an old personality scale that was
originally formulated by cattle and it
was a precursor to the big five.
The reason they used it was because they
had historical data that many thousands
of people had filled out.
So the fact that it wasn't
psychometrically arrayed probably didn't
mean there was no information in it.
So women were hiring sensitivity,
warmth,
and apprehension,
warmth than apprehension.
You could associate it with
agreeableness and neuroticism and men
were more emotionally stable,
more dominant,
more rural,
conscious,
and more vigilant.
Now,
one last thing.
Okay.
This is something to think about.
How do men and women differ in the way
they evaluate mates?
Well,
here's the study.
More than a thousand respondents,
primarily female,
what they looked at was how much each
person,
how much prestige each person had in
their occupation.
So kind of where they were situated in
the dominance hierarchy,
what their income was in education.
So they're all markers,
they're all pretty decent markers of
socio economic status,
or they're pretty decent markers of
status.
So,
and then they looked at how many
partners each person had number of
lifetime partners and number of
preceding year or sexual partners,
um,
lifetime occurrence of simultaneous
partners.
So that was someone who was in a
relationship,
a sexual relationship with more than one
person at the same time and lifetime
frequency of simultaneous partners from
one very seldom or never to five very
often.
Here's their assumption,
the number of partners,
a member of sex a acquires is an index
of how often this individual is chosen
by the other sex.
It's just a definition.
It's an indication of reproductive
fitness as judged by members of the
opposite sex
results.
Male criteria
for women.
The correlation between their fertility
rates and the number of partners in the
previous year was 0.94
so that's basically markers of
biological youth and also markers of
biological health like symmetry or waist
to hip ratio,
which actually tends to be correlated
with reproductive,
um,
fitness because women with lower waist
to hip ratios are generally healthier
because especially in youth,
the acquisition of abdominal fat is
often an indicator of subpar physical
health.
The correlation between the fertility
rate and the number of partners in the
previous year is 0.94 that's all of it,
right?
You never see a correlation to 0.94
anywhere ever.
Males choose fertility indicators,
beauty waist to hip ratio,
youthful appearance,
neon naughtiness facial features,
and Nia naughtiness beans like a infant.
So one of the uh,
one of the markers of feminine beauty is
a face that has small childlike
features,
female criteria,
all respondents.
The correlation between socioeconomic
status and frequency of simultaneous
partners.
For men it's 0.5.
So the,
the status of the man man,
the more likely he has simultaneous
sexual partners,
so it means he's going out with someone
sexually at the same time.
For men it's 0.49.
For Women it's zero age 30 and over.
Correlation between socioeconomic status
and frequency of simultaneous partners.
For men it's 0.8.
For Women it's zero
age 30 to 39 the correlation between
socioeconomic status for women and
frequency of Simile,
tineas partners.
For men it's 0.92 that's a very small
end though.
For Women,
it's 0.11
female criteria.
For men,
it might reflect the tendency on the
part of females to choose high status
partners during their own pre peak
reproductive years.
This might account,
especially for the strong relationship
founded men between the age of 30 and 39
women who typically prefer men three to
eight years older than they are,
would then be in there may mid to late
twenties a time when fecundability
enough sensitivity to male resources is
at its peak
supporting evidence.
I don't believe that,
by the way,
I don't think that women pick men for
the socioeconomic status.
I think that women pick men for the or
ability to climb the status hierarchy
because we forced women in an experiment
that we never published to choose
between those two things.
Wealth versus ability.
The women overwhelmingly chose the
ability,
they just use wealth as a marker of
ability.
Yup.
It was an honors thesis and often honors
thesis,
even if they're publishable,
drift into the thing all due next month
and then they stay there forever.
So cause it's a hard,
it's actually quite hard to turn an
honors thesis into a publishable paper
and if there isn't some single person
driving that forward,
it's,
it's not going to happen.
So that,
that was the only reason.
Okay.
So Trevor's parental investment model
contends that women are more likely than
men to seek a mate who possesses
nonphysical characteristics that
maximize their survival or reproductive
prospects of their offspring.
And we're examining in a Meta analysis
of mate selection research as pre
predicted women accorded more weight
than men to socioeconomic status,
ambitiousness character and intelligence
and the larger differences.
Largest Jeff gender differences were
observed for cues to resource equation,
acquisition status and ambitiousness.
I'll also as predicted gender
preferences were not found in
preferences for characteristics
unrelated to progeny survival,
like sense of humor in general,
personality
were valid,
comparisons can be made.
The findings were generally invariant
across generations,
cultures and research paradigms.
Well,
so what do you think of that?
You know,
the most,
one of the things that it strongly
indicates is that men and women value
different things.
And that's worth thinking about because
the hypothesis,
and I think this is especially strongly
held among people who are very young,
is that the differences are culture and
the life cultural and the life course is
the same.
So,
but that I don't think there's any
evidence that that's the case at all.
I have a lot of experience dealing,
for example,
with large law firms,
and one of the things that happens to
large law firms,
they're very competitive fee and the
people who are partners are making a
tremendous amount of money.
So it would be generally in excess of
300 $400,000 a year.
Now in order to do that,
they have to go through virtual
enslavement during their internship.
It's not called an internship.
It's called an Arctic there articling
and then they have to be on call 80
hours a week.
That's the life.
What happens is that they lose all their
women in their thirties they can't keep
them.
And it's not because they don't try
because they try and the reason they try
is that there just aren't that many
people who are exceptionally able.
And so the law firms are trying to keep
every single person they possibly can.
Who's exceptionally able because those
people produce profits for the law firm.
It's just in their best interest.
But the women all quit and their
thirties
well,
why?
Well,
there's a bunch of reasons.
The first reason is,
is that a woman who's high in the
socioeconomic ladder is going to pick a
man who's hiring the socioeconomic
ladder.
She's gonna marry across or up.
That's what the data show.
And what that means is that most female
potential law partners in their early
thirties are married to someone who
makes a fair bit of money.
So the absolute magnitude of their
income is no longer as relevant as it
would be if they were single.
It's also one of the factors by the way,
that's contributing to the polarization
of society and to those who have a lot
of money in and those who have none.
Because what happens is that men who are
rich will marry women who are poor,
but women who are rich will not marry
men who are poor.
And so what happens across time is that
sort of grinds its way through the
culture is that all the rich women are
with rich men.
And that increases the probability that
wealth is going to pool in the hands of
fewer and fewer people.
What the women seem to come,
what the women seem to
realize or
conclude.
I would say it's two things.
One is that it's just not that much fun
to work for 80 hours a week.
Really.
Like it's,
and if you want to have a life outside
of work,
that's not the way to do it.
And so then you might ask,
well why would anyone work 80 hours a
week?
Because that's the real question.
It's not why some women won't obviously,
why would you?
You know,
the answer is well there's a lot of
status and there's a lot of money
associated with it.
But the thing is is that status is more
important to men than it is for women.
And I think that's individually true and
also genetically true because for men,
status is associated with how attractive
they are to women.
Whereas for women status,
socioeconomic status has nothing to do
with how attractive they are to men.
In fact,
if anything,
one of the things you find for example,
is that as women are
segregated,
so to speak,
higher and higher up the Iq
distribution,
the probability that they'll get married
goes lower and lower.
And the reason for that is that it's
harder.
You know,
once you're at the 95th percentile of
intelligence and you're going to marry a
cross and up,
you've,
you've already limited to one in 20
people in just as it just maintain the
same level.
And so if you're very intelligent,
very educated,
and you also have a very high status job
if you're a woman,
well first of all,
your bloody intimidating to most men.
And second,
the probability that you're going to
choose from,
uh,
a hot spot in the hierarchy lower than
you is very low.
You're just not going to be attracted to
that person.
And so what happens to women who are
exceptionally intelligent is that the
pool of acceptable mating partners
starts to become vanishingly small.
So that combined with the propensity of
women to judge 85% of men in online
dating services as less attractive than
average,
makes it that much more difficult.
Now,
I should say,
you know,
all the prejudice is clearly not on the
side of women.
And by no means,
because if you look at male attitudes
towards women in large online dating
site studies,
you'll find that their preference for
body configuration is 21 years old.
And that doesn't change as the males
age.
So you know,
the selection criteria on both the male
and the female side are extremely harsh.
So,
so
think about that.
See you.
Thank you.
Okay.